as the nation reacts to derek chovin's
conviction a first of its kind study
shows the impact police killings have on
the mental health of many black families
denise valdez has the findings in
today's health watch
[Music]
find the defendant guilty the george
floyd case has gripped the nation
for richard parker seeing another black
man die after interacting with law
enforcement
is overwhelming it gets difficult
i don't want to live in a constant state
of rage and anger and fear
so sometimes i just try to tune it out
and i hate to admit that publicly but
i got to protect my peace a new study
from a group of u.s researchers shows
the significant
negative toll police killings of black
americans has on the mental health
of other black americans weeks where we
have
two or more incidents of these high
profile
acts of racial violence black americans
reports a higher number of poor mental
health days
the study analyzed nearly 50 highly
publicized incidents
from 2013 to 2017 including cases
involving
freddie gray philando castile and
michael brown where officers were not
convicted we find that it's the legal
decisions to not indict
or convict officers that's the strongest
or
only significant predictor of the poor
mentality
parker believes much more work still
needs to be done
what about everybody else you know who
have lost their lives
where's their justice like we can't
just celebrate one when this system is
still broken he's relieved there was a
conviction
this time but he'll keep fighting for a
world where police violence does not
exist
denise valdez 8 news now